and Senate candidate congressman Ted
Budd he continues to expose the
radicalism of far-left democratic
opponent Cherry Beasley the latest Real
Clear Politics numbers have Bud with a
4.5 percentage point lead here with the
latest on the state of the race uh
Republican Senate candidate in North
Carolina Ted Budd and he brought brought
along his fellow Carolinian although
South Carolina Lindsey Graham is with
you uh welcome both of you uh Ted you've
been able to build up a lead it's gone
from one point to two points now four
and a half points what is happening in
North Carolina that is bringing you more
support almost on a weekly basis
Sean again thanks for having us we're
all Carolinians today but I would say
this is about inflation about crime and
about education we're talking about the
things that the voters want to get
better in their lives and everything
that Democrats are doing is making life
worse everything that I'm doing is about
making life better for not just us here
in North Carolina or South Carolina but
us in this in this whole country and
Sherry Beasley is running away from her
record she's defended cop killer she's
thrown out indictments for sex offenders
she's against GPS tracking for child
molesters the more we dig into her
record the worse it gets and they know
that I'm for fixing inflation I'm for
making crime less not worse and I'm
forgiving parents a say in their
education the more we talk about that
the more we win but we can't let up in
the next 11 days that's why I hope
everybody goes to tedbud.com and figures
out that we don't have the tech
billionaires on our side like she does
but we do have you and your viewers on
our side and so we need help yeah you
know Lindsay it used to be Democrats
would hide their radicalism try and run
as moderates they're not hiding it
anymore
I mean you know the issues come down to
radical policies on energy wide open
borders uh defund dismantle no bail laws
it comes down to woke education versus
traditional curriculum in schools and
they're saying it openly and no
restrictions at all in abortion they all
seem to be you know out radicaling each
other thinking that's going to what
resonate with the American people
especially in light of two years of
Biden
well they got a they're in a bind here
if if they don't say the things you're
talking about nobody gives them money
just listen to what Ted said about Miss
Beasley she ran Statewide and only lost
about 400 votes Trump won North Carolina
by less than one percentage points so
Ted's from one of the best races in the
country but don't let these polls fool
you these people surge at the right time
so if they say no to D.C statehood say
no to changing the filibuster try to
secure the Border they'll lose all the
money so she raised 13 million in the
last quarter Ted raised four from
October the 1st October the 19th the
last reporting period she raised five
Ted raised one and a half your audience
has been incredibly generous tedbud.com
11 days left everything he said needs to
be in a commercial I don't know where
all this money comes from Sean you know
what I was just going to ask you right
this this is Lindsay this is every
single state every race gubernatorial
race senatorial race where are they
getting these tens of millions of
dollars from has anybody looked into it
well I sure will I just don't believe
this is legit on the up and up but I do
know this that the money is real 13 to 4
he's being outraged four to one he's got
the best story really of anybody running
about being a reliable conservative
there's a headwind for Democrats but the
next 11 days tedbud.com if he didn't get
the money he needs and you have sent
money like you helped Herschel like
three nights ago you have no idea what
your audience did for Herschel all these
people are being pounded so let's close
will the flourish every liberal in
America is trying to take over Georgia
and North Carolina and Florida I live
near all these folks we need
conservatives like the people listening
to help JD please help JD but this guy
has run the best race maybe in the
entire country he's leading in a state
where it's hard to lead tedbud.com pray
vote and give
well absolutely we're going to stay hard
we're going to we're going to stay
humble and work hard and go the next 11
days and win this but we need your help
at tedbud.com and we just ask for
people's prayers support and if they're
in North Carolina for their vote amen
all right